d'abord sur la question que vous m'avez
posé sur la démographie médicale alors
pardon si je n'ai pas été clair en fait
je faisais référence au travaux de
l'omdps et de l'adresse qui font état
des perspectives médicales à 2030 en
indiquant que nous avons un creux pour
les médecins enfin pour les professions
médicales jusqu'en 2030 et qu'à partir
de 2030 la démographie remonte c'est la
raison pour laquelle que jusqu'en 2030
nous aurons des difficultés ces travaux
conduit par l'ondps avec l'adresse et
présenter l'année dernière on fait état
de projection d'un besoin de
développement des formations médicales
de plus 14 % en effectif au cours des 5
prochaines années je on pourrait vous
retransmettre leurs travaux mais ce sont
les grands chiffres si vous voulez qui
qui me font dire que nous avons des
difficultés de prise en charge médicale
jusqu'en 2030 et que nous devons adapter
notre organisation pour y faire face
voilà pour le premier point s'agissant
des PNM nous avons des chiffres
également par l'adresse
et nous avons des chiffres réguliers que
ce soit le nombre d'effectifs dans les
établissements par catégorie
d'établissement par catégorie
professionnelle en revanche nous n'avons
pas de système d'information qui nous
permettent à tout moment de dire quelles
sont les vacances de poste le nombre de
professionnels ça nous ne l'avons pas
donc quand nous souhaitons avoir des
éléments nous conduisons des enquêtes
avec les établissements de santé et leur
représentant qui nous permettent de
remonter des données mais nous n'avons
pas de méga système d'information qui
nous permettent en tout cas à ce jour
d'avoir ce type d'éléments c'est c'est
ça la question mais par contre nous
avons des grandes évolutions nous savons
que le nombre d'effectifs de PNL a
progressé maintenant je pense qu'il y a
aussi des difficultés et d'ailleurs vous
l'avez vu ça nous a conduit à augmenter
le nombre de quotas de formation en IFSI
en 2020 2021 et 2022 et probablement des
travaux du même type que celui que l'on
dps a conduit pour les personnes
médicaux seraient utile à mon sens pour
les personnels non médicaux c'est
peut-être ça que pardon que je voulais
clarifier pratique vous pourrez nous
donner tous des éléments par rapport au
sauf s'ils ont déjà été donné mais je
pense qu'on a besoin de compléter
beaucoup pour vos l'audition c'est
normal par des chiffres par des réponses
très précises donc ça merci par avance
de nous donner des questions moi j'avais
quelque chose c'est sur enfin je sais
pas comment appeler ça l'observation ou
avoir une vision de la situation
actuelle parce que bon vous nous dites
il y a des études
sur le nombre de praticiens il faudra la
même étude sur les les
personnels non médicaux moi ce que je
trouvais étonnant si vous voulez c'est
dans un pays comme le nôtre ben on sache
pas à l'instant T je dirais merci c'est
tout sur tout le monde
là on peut et nous on sentait pas non on
sait pas combien il y a de
personnellement quand on sait pas quel
est le flux des personnel on sait pas où
passe nos étudiants en médecine quand
ils ont terminé leurs études
je sais pas un moment il va bien falloir
qu'on arrive à avoir
est-ce que c'est de l'observation est-ce
que c'est des indicateurs qui soient
actualisé régulièrement sans passer par
des grandes études par des organismes et
tout ça
oui ou par des cabinets préférés ça
c'est un autre sujet et une autre
commission d'enquête monsieur le
Président mais
voyez est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à voir quand même quelque chose
un tableau de bord de la situation sans
à chaque fois demander à l'hôpital en
voie ça me paraît ça me paraît un peu
ubuesque et j'ai l'impression ou alors
je sais pas quoi qu'on arrive pas à
faire simple et qu'on est toujours
obligé de faire compliqué mais je sais
pas peut-être que vous avez des
arguments pour me dire qu'il faut que ce
soit compliqué qu'on ne peut pas faire
simple mais voyez ce que je veux dire
comment se fait-il que la direction
générale de l'organisation des soins ne
puisse pas avoir des tableaux de bord
actualisés de du nombre de personnel en
soins vous voyez ce que je veux dire
oui sur le terrain quoi comment ça se
passe sur le terrain on est pas
totalement dépourvu d'outils quand même
parce que on a quand même des voilà
parce que nous avons en fait d'abord les
travaux statistiques qui sont lourds en
fait mais que conduit l'adresse qui nous
permet d'avoir régulièrement des données
ensuite nous avons des enquêtes à dogs
et puis nous sommes en lien permanent
que ce soit avec les ARS les fédérations
les conférences hospitalières les
syndicats enfin on a quand même des
relais avec lesquels nous travaillons
beaucoup après ça fait partie d'un autre
chantier que nous avons enfin que j'ai
peut-être insuffisamment évoqué devant
vous aujourd'hui nous avons un chantier
numérique énorme et compris qui
introduit de la simplification je n'ai
parlé que du volley j'ai envie de dire
patient avec la téléconsultation ou la
télésurveillance mais le numérique c'est
aussi un enjeu d'amélioration des
systèmes d'information des remontées de
données et puis aussi de simplification
de la vie des professionnels qu'il soit
administratifs ou soignants
[Musique]